new research shows that dangers for
children who play football
could be worse than previously thought
the study in the journal annals of
Neurology compares kids who start
playing tackle football before age 12 to
others who start later researchers found
the younger players will on average
develop cognitive and emotional symptoms
associated with the degenerative brain
disease CTE much earlier Jamie yuccas
spoke to a California family whose son
began playing when he was nine the
family blames football for his early
death I'd loved my said he he was just a
wonderful kid Gregory ransom is
heartbroken about the loss of his 13
year old son James can be hard to look
at these sometimes just over a year
before his death
James suffered a brutal hit to the head
while playing football is alignment
after the game his dad noticed blood
around his ear he was known in the
neighborhood as getting fall down and
and just getting right back up and go
play and he didn't he didn't never cried
him I talked to him about these things
and he said well I get my bell rung all
the time playing football and it was
shocking to me to hear that James's
sister Julia said his personality began
to change immediately after the hit just
look into his eyes and he just wasn't
the same person and just you could see
that inside he knew he was hurting and
he was struggling so that was really
hard to deal with as a sibling just
seeing that happen and not knowing what
to do
James suffered from short-term memory
and vision loss and OCD he attempted
suicide just three months after the hit
and was committed into a mental
institution for a month nearly a year
later he took his own life he was happy
a friendly kid compassionate kid you
think this is all because of football I
know it was a new study published in
Annals of Neurology looked at the brains
of 246 deceased amateur and professional
football players 211 of them had the
degenerative brain disease known as
chronic traumatic encephalopathy or CTE
which could be caused by repetitive hits
to the head the study showed kids who
began playing tackle football before the
age of 12 began showing cognitive and
emotional symptoms associated
CTE an average of 13 years earlier than
those who started after 12
I think it's concerning because it was
such a change dr. Ann McKie of Boston
University is the study's lead
researcher children's brains are rapidly
developing between 8 and 12 years old
they're laying down new networks they're
their pruning the different connections
there
they're sort of enhancing their brain
lineman of the year the Ransom family
did not get James's brain tested for CTE
but they hope to prevent his injuries
from occurring in other children is
there something specific you want to see
happen with youth football I want
parents and mothers and fathers to know
the science and to know what's happening
to their sons brains because if a mother
knows what's happening inside that
helmet she's not gonna let her son out
on the football field that was Jamie
yuccas reporting from Orange County
California the study also showed that
for each year or earlier kids began
playing football they could begin to
experience symptoms associated with CTE
two and a half years sooner what i was
really telling that hearing from that
neuroscientist about just how vulnerable
yeah the brain of a young child is
especially during the ages of eight and
ten i can only imagine the anguish these
parents are going through yeah and then
what they tell you is you know just
shake it off when you get your bell rung
that's not that way what's changing
that's right it is changing